alright here's how I do interlaken
corkscrews first get your large
corkscrew and another large corkscrew
then get two small curves and then get
three straight pieces and then get
another large corkscrew into the same
direction and then you should have an
interlocking corkscrew now I usually do
to actually get some good pot over here
because obviously nobody wants to have
it like that is to remove that and then
you have two interlocking cork screws
which you can connect in any way which
you want one way I like to do is to go
up and then get a large curve then gets
a medium curve another medium curve and
then go back down with a large curve and
then you should come out at the second
code through without any problems
another way in which I like to do it is
to have four pieces that goes straight
up like that then have a medium curve
and have three large curves and then go
back down and make sure to have a large
curve in a different direction and then
you should come out at the second
corkscrew like that now obviously these
were just simple ideas you can really
connect them in any way which you want
to but make sure to keep it really short
because you don't want to lose too much
speed when it enters the second
corkscrew in any case that was this
quick tutorial and thank you for
watching